trump and i didn't always see eye to eye
on everything in our interview but one
thing we did agree about was the royal
family the former president didn't hold
back calling harry whipped lavishing
praise on the queen and giving his
thoughts on the future of the monarchy
and the prince andrew scandal but first
i started by asking him about that
historic state visit you know i met the
queen yeah it was supposed to be for 20
minutes i saw you just after you saw it
right it was supposed to be just a quick
meeting
and it was beautiful the pompad ceremony
nobody does it like the english i don't
know what it is but nobody does it like
we have a certain you know but i met her
and it turned out to be more than an
hour substantially
because she liked me and i liked her and
she's let it be known she like me and i
let it be honest i've had other members
of the royal family tell me they enjoyed
your company we had a great time and
then they honored the united states but
they honored me that night which is
really the honor of the country and it
was at the top level and i sat next to
her we talked the whole night
and somebody said
we've never seen her smile so much we
had a great time
she was laughing and smiling they said
they've never seen her have such a good
time at a state dinner you know normally
they're a little boring okay this wasn't
boring so
i have a lot of respect for the queen
she's incredible she loves her country i
think she's incredible look at her she's
been queen for what 70 years or
something and
she's never made a mistake even when the
guy broke into a room
sits him down talks to him quietly does
what everything she's done now some of
the kids it's you know they make a
little mistake every once in a while
sometimes a big one what did you make of
this
andrew's game well it was a terrible
thing it was a you know terrible thing i
think terrible for a lot of people but
but
the queen i don't know has she ever even
made a mistake
she's an incredible woman i'm not a fan
of megan yeah i'm not a fan and i wasn't
right from the beginning what did you
make and i think
i think poor harry is being led around
by his nose and i think he's an
embarrassment you know here's my issue
with it i think that
they've quit the country they've quit
royal duty they're living in luxury in
california
they want to use their royal titles to
exploit them for massive financial gain
without any of the duty that comes with
the royal titles i don't think you can
have your royal cake and eat it that's
my argument about it so i want to know
what's going to happen when harry
decides he's had enough of being bossed
around or maybe when she decides that
she likes some other guy better i want
to know what's going to happen
when it ends
okay do you think it's going to end i do
i've been a very good predictor as you
know i predicted almost everything it'll
end and it'll end bad and i wonder if
harry's gonna go back on his hands and
knees back into
uh the beautiful city of london and say
please you know i think harry has been
led down a path i found it when i heard
he wasn't going to prince phillips
memorial terrible
i found that i couldn't believe that
yeah he would not go to that he was at
the super bowl he was a texas rodeo but
he couldn't find time to get on a plane
i think it was it was a terrible thing
many terrible things that might have
been
as you mentioned it that might have been
the worst of all
because he was you know like her he was
a tough cookie too i remember years ago
prince philip came to
new york and we were in the plaza hotel
and there were many people wanting to
meet him
and
we were all taking a picture with him
many people and the photographers said
i'll never forget this he was tough the
photographer said please move back there
were like 30 of us
and he said no you moved back
and that was simple i said that's pretty
good you know this guy's tough
but i'll never forget that i don't mean
that in a derogatory i mean he was
direct good way yeah instead of having
this whole group of people moving back
plenty of room the photographer and he
immediately moved back i said wow
i mean
the queen had to be pretty tough because
i think she was he was tough when he
died i think it was a devastating moment
for the queen i think they had a great
relationship but he was a strong guy i
never forgot a little moment right he
just said no you moved back
and he didn't say it in a nice way
because the photographer was pushing
everybody around a little bit foolishly
but um
i thought it was terrible when he didn't
go to the funeral of prince philip yeah
i think i think the harry
situation has
is going to unfold in a much different
way
if you were the queen is it at the stage
now would you remove their royal title i
would i take i the only thing i disagree
with the queen on probably one of the
only things ever
is that i think she should have said if
that's your choice fine
but you no longer have titles you're no
longer and frankly
don't come around you just because her
loyalty is to the country she said that
many times her loyalty is to the country
and i think that he has been so
disrespectful to the country
and it's a great country
i own a lot of things there i own a
place called turnberry and in aberdeen i
own and i mean we have aberdeen is
beautiful the oil capital of europe
and i own things there and i love that
country it's incredible scotland i love
i love turnberry i love what i did there
i built things there it's a great girl
and i respect great one of the best in
the world and i will tell you um
she is she is more passionate about
her role and and the country it's going
to be very interesting
someday she won't be there right it'll
be very interesting what happens and i
know charles pretty well
and i think camilla i think you sat with
him i do and and i'll tell you what uh
she was on my right the queen was on my
left
and i said queen
i really have to talk to camilla for a
little while too you know we no we we
couldn't break apart and i talked to
camilla and camilla was so nice
you know different than i thought she
was funny she was smart quick
i really liked she was great i like her
too and
uh i like charles i mean he's serious do
you think they'll make a good king and
queen when that time comes i hope so i
think it's it's a it's going to be
tricky
he's going to have to be
you know it's going to be tricky because
they are truly replacing you talking
about a legend this woman
she's got to have the all-time record
greatest i mean in your lifetime is she
the greatest of all the leaders of any
kind well so my mother was born in
scotland and i remember as a little boy
anything where the queen was on anything
at all where
and it was the pomp and ceremony but my
mother had tremendous
love and respect
for the young queen at that time he
would have been a kid when she got
coronated right i was in the mid 50s but
but my mother wouldn't leave the screen
and she'd go back to scotland almost
every year you know she loved scotland
she loved but she loved the queen
and
so does everybody and for this person to
come along and
criticize the queen
it's just you just can't do that so
it'll be interesting to see how it all
works out harry is whipped do you know
the expression i'm familiar with i won't
use the full expression but harry is
whipped like no person i think i've ever
seen the most wicked man in the world i
don't know that's going to be a big one
but he is he is a whipped man